I know that there's something wrong with
me I just don't know what it is you know
but there is a something wrong I don't
know what I got dropped in my head or
you know or something you know what I
mean or cougar not a cougar cougar I
don't know I've never I've never seen a
cougar attacked you I've never seen a
cooker in my life now I would say like
maybe what was your Trina thought when
you said cougar just now some sort of
animal like attacked you yeah yeah
I I had this recurring dream that when I
was a kid I was in the forest because
there was like Woods by my house you
know because we're like you know
Frontiers people
those words next to the um the country
club that in the woods it's still Woods
right and they had this reoccurring
dream that was attacked by some sort of
creature out there
like a coyote or something
okay how would you decipher that dream
why would you be attacked by I think
maybe I was attacked by an animal oh
yeah yeah yeah your dad that's him
you're right that's the kind that's true
that's the coyote yeah yeah a full-blown
mammal attacked you it was your father
yeah he yelled at me the only memory I
have of him is he of the jacket I lost
remember I told you that yeah
I know what say it again I remember I
remember my dad going let's go park
to the park yeah let's go to park
because I think my mom was telling him
like you have to do more so we just sat
on this park bench in a park
why is that
okay that was the most diabolical evil
love what I've never [__] seated
that was [__] up what you did Andreas
right I was projected yeah yeah
so we're on a park bench and I remember
he didn't bring a ball or anything
we just sat there but I remember being
this is nice you know because he you
know he's never invited me into anything
and then we laughed and I forgot my
jacket there and I remember him yelling
at me for like yelling leaving the
jacket but that's my only real memory of
my dad doing something
kind you know I mean damn but followed
up by something not so kind what do you
mean well like you got interested but
still even that was attention I guess
you know yeah but I just I don't know
why I just got into that but yeah maybe
that's the dream that I have but he's
the animal in the forest oh maybe yeah
and he he's a cougar so I wasn't wrong
yeah mountain lion we have them in
California yeah we do yeah yeah are we
good now Andreas
that was crazy okay that was crazy you
want to hurt me huh no
[Laughter]
I didn't come out normally
it's something in your throat you have
resentments absolutely no you know yeah
who do you think has more resentments
towards you George or Andreas when you
look at both of them I I have a feeling
that everyone has resentments
I think we should air them out loud
because it's the fourth hundredth
episode yeah you know what I mean and
and I just want to say to people
um that's listening or not listening
right that I will never quit this
podcast this podcast will go on as long
as I have breath in my body it's my home
just listen to that song that we came up
with and all the experiences we've had
on this podcast do you remember
recording that song together I remember
that that was amazing you tell us the
story for the audience listening well
she always has to push me to do things
so I was like I was that's not true
you're already wrong oh you were on
GarageBand once that's what I'm saying
okay and I was playing I would play You
songs yeah on GarageBand but I never
thought about singing on top of them I
think you encouraged me to sing and we
were in bed yeah and then you were like
oh listen to this and then you played
around with gibberish and then you go
you take the second half and I played
around with gibberish
we did it once once only and that was it
that was it when you listen to the
episode do you hear her part two yeah
yeah that's amazing yeah it's amazing
that was a one shot one shot deal we
never try to fix it or anything we were
like oh this sounds insane I like it and
there's another song that you hate
that's on there that we all recorded
called Good Town oh yeah yeah well I
didn't like that one yeah so we all sang
another song called Good Town and Bryce
I still have it Bryce no Bryce is not on
it Bryce is on it Bryce is on it
I I could I actually bet my life for
that he's not he's not know your own
single I mean he is no you're single
he wrote the lyrics but you sang on it
oh that's that's what it is and we're
equally tone deaf yeah yeah equally
toned us yeah but um but good town you
guys didn't didn't like I mean we can we
re-release the club uh no thank you
why thank you yeah I just like
melodically I just don't even like it
yeah oh yeah it was also a weird time
and your guys relationship because it
timed up with uh Red Dead Redemption and
that's when you were playing like yeah
that was 100 resentment that was a
resentment period yeah it was red dead
resentment yeah I have I have a I mean
did I show you this photo and this is
and it and when I I want to show you
this photo I'll send it to you um it I
realize I have a problem
okay can I just show you what yeah yeah
and you're gonna find this to be
interesting this photo okay show me can
I please no it's not so it's it's
basically me
so we played Phoenix bad friends and I
right right and Andrew and my mom came
and my mom and I were sitting on a couch
together and she was doing this and I
was playing
um
my um
we're not Game Boy what's it called um
yeah but but her and I were just lost in
our gadgets right and I realized that
my mom is it's something that we do to
not live in the moment and not yeah be
here it's a coping yeah because of just
generational trauma and stuff right it's
just like we just and Andrew are we were
ripping us apart on the couch
like oh look at these two you know I
mean but it's like it's just something
that we do it's sad it must be nice to
not have to cope you guys are coping in
that moment I get it and I totally get
it I'm my mom when she comes over does
she say anything to me she doesn't she
cleans around me yes and I'm like ma do
you want to watch a movie No and then
she just leaves right yeah I have to
force her to interact with me and I know
that she's just coping so I get it I
totally do yeah but that was the first
time I realized that my mom does it and
that we we're just kind of like similar
in that way but I don't think that it's
a healthy thing because you know
everyone also when you took you see the
photo right there's 40 people in the
room having a party
and we're just
well I you know there was something I
was almost there to get the golden clock
so I have an excuse but you know what I
mean you know about the cam you know
about the golden clock
it's okay
terrible terrible question it's okay
it's okay Cam how do you know can can
he's her editor he's been for years he's
one of ourselves we've met before I'm at
the live show how many times
and we have conversation not really